Hey, what's going on is bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you,
seeing how you weeks go and what
are you doing? Are you driving home?
This podcast is a little late today. It's
flying to Nashville. You drive it home.
Why don't you,
you know,
one of the things you should do is just
try to take a deep breath and just,
you don't let people in that just
makes it go by so much nicer.
Be a courteous driver.
Don't be a city is driver when
he always has to fucking run.
You know what I mean?
I love when they do shit you rhyme stuff.
It's easy to remember.
They just treat you like a fucking child.
Speaking of which,
speaking of which,
I just had a fucking credit card shut
off on me. Cause when I was in Europe,
I miss the fucking payment was gone
for like a month. But I came back,
I paid him right back and then, uh,
I don't what the fuck out, you know,
I left my house getting the kitchen
done, something happened, Baba Baba, boo.
I didn't get there in time and they
would just like, yeah, go fuck yourself.
You miss two payments of six months.
So they're like,
so like if you want to reapply,
it's like I don't want to reapply,
just turn the fucking thing back on.
I sent, I gave you all the money.
You got it and you think you just waiting
for the check to clip and the first
lady said that they were going
to turn it back on, you know,
after I talked to them for like, like an
hour, not an hour. It felt like an hour.
It's probably like eight minutes. That's
an actual, it was the usual bullshit,
you know, you get on there, it's just
like, hi, who am I speaking with?
And then I always say my name and they go,
what's your zip code?
I tell him that and they
go, hey, what's, what's uh,
what's the name of your first gold
fish had fucking tell him that, right?
And then they go, okay,
what's the problem? I go,
well, a, the problem is this.
And I go, well, that's not my
department. I'm going to transfer you.
And then they transfer you to
somebody else and then just go, hi,
who am I speaking with? It's like,
bitch, I just fucking talk. I just gave,
why did I have to give it to
the first person? Why does it,
the first person just fucking
say, what is your problem? Okay.
And then they go, oh, well
that's not my department,
so I'm not going to fucking waste any
of your time or my time getting all this
information up. By the time I get to
the person that I want to talk to,
there'll be like, yeah, who am I speaking
with? I'll be like William, you know, uh,
I, but you know, I've been
doing all right with the temper.
I've been, you know, I've been
out, I've been doing all right.
So I just told the lady, I just said,
listen, I do a lot of business with you.
But the problem is,
is I pay mine off at the end of every
month cause I don't want to pay any
fucking interest.
Which is why my credit is only fair.
I fair credit.
Because they don't make any fucking,
they don't make the amount
of money that they want.
They want me running on that fucking
wheel until I die and I just do it.
So they punished me.
Why do I give a shit?
You know, so now I've got to reapply.
So I told them, I said, look,
I'm not doing business with
whose mastercard. I'm like,
I'm not doing business with you guys
anymore. And the whole time, um,
I'm trying to threaten them
and puff up my chest. I'm like,
these people do billions and billions
of dollars with the business a month.
Did they think you think you,
they give a fuck that you paste pasty.
Freckle das is just going to go over
to the visa. I mean within five years,
visa is going to by mastercard
or mastercard is gonna buy,
visa will be all down to one
world. Fucking Bang. Oh my
God. In the future, Jesus,
can you imagine that phone call?
It's going to be ridiculous.
We you're going to gain,
they don't even give a fuck now.
I can't imagine when it's just going
to be down to one God damn back. Um,
I dunno,
but at the end of the day it was my fuck
up and I guess they have an algorithm
and if you miss two of them,
okay.
Oh Jesus Christ. And now I got to
apply for a fucking credit card.
I don't even know how to do that.
Back in the day you went to
the bank and you got a forum.
I'm sure now it's all done online.
I'm sure I could Google it.
I'm sure I could make my life easy and
just fucking Google the goddamn saying,
but um,
okay.
I didn't want to do it. You
know, fuck it. Fuck it. You know,
like a Goddamn Nashville.
It's like a bike.
Maybe I could write a country song
about losing my fucking credit card.
I go down to one of these
honky tonks down here,
if that's what they really even are.
I guess they're not, are they? Um,
anyway,
so I stayed in this hotel in Washington
DC that actually really liked by in the
hotel,
the hotel liaison on New Jersey
Avenue and Avenue d and um,
I, I'm walking in, right? I check in and
everything's fine. Well, it wasn't fine.
The computers were down,
but the staff was just great there.
But on the wall they got this
picture of this old guy and by old,
I mean he's probably about
seven years older than me,
so he's really fucking open. Not like
he's not going to die soon. He's just,
you know, the creepy guy, Hooters, right.
So he's got the male pattern
baldness thing going on.
He shaved his head down here. I'm
just doing the best he can. You know,
any standing there in this trench coat,
you smoking fucking cigar. So my God,
that's a cool picture.
Maybe they got a cigar lounge
chair or something like that.
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
So then I get the elevator and I'd go up
to my floor was staying on the fucking
sixth floor and uh,
it's just a series of
pictures of this guy.
I go up to the gym and it's just him
smoking the Gar is the cigar basically
trying to be the most
interesting man in the world.
It's the weirdest fucking photo shoot.
And I'm like, who the fuck is this guy?
So the guy who owned the hotel, nobody
at the fucking hotel knows who he is.
Then they have this giant photo of him
and it looks like he's standing outside
of the White House gate, like some
really official looking building.
And he's sitting there in his trench coat
and he's looking at his phone and this
is,
you know,
this drop dead gorgeous 20 something
standing there and like sort of a business
suit,
but it's like Hillary Clinton on top,
but then like a mini skirt and then she
has like high heels and she's sitting
there looking frustrated.
Like,
there's nothing more she wants in the
world and this man's attention and he
doesn't have time for it because he's
trying to figure out the fucking world.
So if anybody knows this,
somebody must ask the question.
Maybe it's on the Internet. Who
the fuck is that guy? And uh,
why didn't he run for president?
Because he would fit in tremendously.
But those two fucking knit weeks from
last night, by the way, I didn't,
I didn't watch a second of
it cause I was on the, uh,
I was on stage doing my last show
before I take my special tomorrow night.
And um,
to be honest with you,
the two of them discussed me
so much that I, I didn't even,
it didn't even dawn on me to
fucking watch it. And I actually,
I caught the end of the cubs game
and,
uh,
what, what were they up
like fucking tend to, to,
you know what's funny is I hate Donald
Trump, but I gotta tell you something.
His fucking hotel is the shit and uh,
it looks like a giant castle and I'm,
me and Bart,
nick went in there to drink and I was
hoping it going to be a bunch of people
and then talking about Trump and
I was going to fuck with them.
An actual act like I was into
Hillary, but, um, it's tremendous man.
I felt like I was on the fucking titanic.
It was absolutely beautiful.
It used to be an old post office or
something like that. So, uh, you know,
anyway, so I went in there
and watch the fucking, uh,
and there's probably some psycho
people out there like, Huh,
I wouldn't spend a fucking diamond.
Good, good. I'm glad you would.
I'm glad you would. I'm glad you
wouldn't and I'm glad you weren't there.
All right. There was this
Asian dude walking around
and he had like this fucking,
he had this sport coat on that was,
there was blue with white stars,
like the f the American flag.
And then his pants were like,
almost like what the Indiana Hoosiers
where their warmups, it's the red.
So he's dressed like the American flag.
And he was walking around doing this
dead on Donald Trump impression.
It was actually fucking funny as hell.
So we had a good time
hanging out there and, um,
I got to watch the end of the
cubs game. So now it's two, two
and uh,
I dunno,
like the fucking world series.
The most interesting world series is
the cubs versus the fucking Cleveland
Indians.
And uh,
I didn't want the cubs to go down three
one as much as I liked the Dodgers,
I always liked the Dodgers because I hated
the Yankees when I was a kid. And, uh,
we can never beat him.
So then the Dodgers would always meet him
in the world series and I watched them
lose in 77 78 and then
finally get them in 81.
And as I've mentioned before,
Tommy John,
who the surgeries named after was pitching
for the Los Angeles Dodgers in 77 78
loss to the Yankees.
He goes to the Yankees in 1981.
They meet the Dodgers and the Dodgers
beat the Yankees. It was like when, uh,
who is that guy? Uh,
what the fuck's his name?
Yeah.
Mari La.
He just got his 500 fucking goal in
hockey when he fucking, he was on,
he was on the pens and they
lost to the fucking red wings.
Why do I keep thinking dominant?
Kaushik is something begins with an m.
I'm the worst dude. The second the
fucking season's over. I forget.
Everybody's fun.
This is ridiculous.
This guy's like a superstar and I
haven't been able to watch any games,
although the NHL actually reached out to
me to tell me how to watch the Games on
the Internet.
And um,
but I was going to say the analogy would
be like when that guy played with the
finger,
was lost to the Redwings next year was
on the red wings and then lost to the
penguins. Then the next year you
went to the Black Hawks and a,
I remember talking about
that in the podcast. I,
this guy loses three different years in
the fucking finals on three different
teams three years in a row. I don't
think that that would have ever happened.
Jesus,
that was a long fucking way to go.
MMM.
Anyways, plowing ahead here. So
congratulations to the Cleveland Indians.
Holy Shit of Cavaliers
win the championship.
And now you guys are in the world series.
Just Molan down the competition.
You swept my Boston red sox.
Three three games to none of my
Boston Red Sox who I have not watched
religiously since 2010
mmm.
The tail end of the steroid and fucking
shit. I just got sick of it. Uh,
but I'm coming back though.
I always come back in October
and then they beat the Blue Jays.
Four games to one.
So you're going to be,
is could you self is is
if I was Terry Francona,
I do. First of all, I get
on the treadmill. All right.
Can you looking a little swollen? All
right. But other than that, I would want,
you know, I would want to play the
world series and like two days,
I would want to just keep
fucking moving along,
keep it moving rather than
everybody sitting around
fucking cooling off a little
bit.
So this is going to be the big battle,
the battle between the team that has a
one in 108 fucking years versus the team
that hasn't won in close to 60.
So I guess you're supposed to be for the
cubs. Um, it'd be great to see the cubs,
but also be great to see the Indians.
You know,
I had family out there when I
was growing up in Ohio and uh,
you don't, you know, where the cubs lost
me. I don't know if I brought this up,
I talked about this on uh,
the sports junkies in DC.
They lost me with Steve Bartman thing.
You know,
the way they went after that guy was the
exact same way every other fucking city
would have included Boston.
But the thing was the cubs had like that,
that fucking, you know, I dunno the, the,
you know, hey, let's play too.
And, you know, we just, you know,
you just root for where the lovable
losers they had like that thing,
like despite the fact
that they were losing,
they had this happy go lucky sort of vibe
about them and the way they went after
that guy, the way they put his fucking
phone number out there, I was like,
these guys,
I just a bunch of fucking animals the
same way they would have done that in
Boston, you know, lease,
we yelled at a player,
you know what I mean? We went
after Bill Buckner, poor bastard,
had to move to like fucking
Idaho. So anyways, let's, uh,
I'm just bullshitting here.
Let's get down to what the
fuck I need to talk about here.
I am in Nashville right now. I
just moved, the computer helped us,
isn't gonna make too much noise.
I'm doing my special tomorrow and uh,
I want to thank everybody who's
been coming out to my shows, uh,
during the writing of this,
not really writing the fucking
spewing it out on stage. Um,
so tomorrow night is the
big fucking thing, right?
So all week I was just almost like
wanting to just get past doing the special
right. Let me just set this down. I
was just looking at it with like, dude,
once I fucking do that special, I don't
have shit for the rest. I'll do comics,
come home with Denis leary and those guys.
That's my only other Gig and
I'm just fucking home. I'm
going to cook up a storm,
I'm going to fly helicopters,
I'm gonna to play drums and the
edit this pumpkin series. I'm,
I'm not doing fucking
shit. And um, you know,
there's always a pressure whenever
you're doing a special. And, um,
I was kind of dreading it
and uh,
finally hit me last night, you know,
cause I'm never late working on my act.
I'm just having fun.
But this weekend was like,
I gotta get this thing down from two
hours down to about a buck, you know,
an hour and a half, one 20, somewhere
in there, which I was able to do,
but just like, my whole approach was, it
was just getting too fucking robotic. And,
um,
last night on stage I was just like,
Aye,
you never know what you're going to
say when you walk out there. I mean,
you know what you bit saw, but you
just fuck around. Just do that.
And I did that and I was able to kind
of get into the zone so I've never done
that on a special or whatever.
So I think I'm going to try at least to
be in that head space and maybe try to
do, um, remember to enjoy it,
which I know I'm going to.
Um,
but uh,
I got tonight off, I kind of
wish I did and I think, you know,
like I feel like the fucking Indian
soap, I don't cool off here, but um,
I'm really fucking psych. Matt. I'm
going to get this thing finally recorded.
I should have recorded it months ago
and it's going to be this big fucking
weight off of my chest.
And then I can, you know,
I told you my favorite thing ever.
My favorite thing ever is
the day after this special.
You got no jokes and I get to start it
all over again. You know what I mean?
It's like taking a bunch of shit to
goodwill and getting the fuck out of there
before you buy a bunch of more
shit that you don't need. Right.
And then you fucking start all over
again. Probably a bad analogy, but, um,
anyways,
just made a ton of noise set.
But I do have to touch the computer
when I go to look the shit here.
MMM.
All right.
So although even though I've watched,
I've watched a bunch of highlights.
MMM.
You know,
of the NHL coming up so far and what
I've realized and as Joe Barton,
he told me, you know, the worst thing,
the Bruins basically did the worst
fucking thing that you can do if you're
trying to rebuild your team.
All right.
The last two years in the row
on the last day of the season,
we got bounced out of the playoffs.
We were like the number
ninth fucking position.
So not only do we not get a
good draft pick, we lose out on,
I'll play off revenue money.
It just sucks.
And we've done it two years
in a row and you know,
a couple of years ago or I guess last
year when we fucking dealt everybody away
to clear money for the fucking salary
cap or whatever the fuck we were going to
do.
You know,
we haven't made any
fucking exciting moves.
It just looks like it's going
to be more the same. What?
We're going to be struggling
where our big three marsh,
Sean Sciara in Berge and Ron are
going to try to get us there again.
And um,
I don't know.
I,
it's less like Toronto did it.
Smart Toronto just fucking gave away the
farm shit the bed and now they've got
this Austin Matthews guy to build around.
Winnipeg did the same thing and now they
got this fucking guy when she looked at
his name and I don't even
know how to say it. Like yeah,
I already forgot his fucking name, but
he's a monster. He had a hat trick.
It's like the two of them, all
of a sudden, it's just like,
at least the new guys that this is
this. I mean, I know it's really early,
but it's just like they are looking
like, I dunno. It's like that.
Another Crosby, another Lemieux,
another fucking, you know.
TEEMU Salani what happens?
Some big fucking Ovechkin goal scoring
guide that did we miss out on that guy
again? We've never had that guy. My,
we've never had that guy. The closest we
ever had to that guy. We had Bobby yard,
he was a fucking defensemen.
We've never had the,
the fucking guy. Wait,
Phil Esposito. I'm sorry.
But that was before my time.
What?
Since I've been watching him since Ray
Bourque had the mustache and wore number
seven and 1979, 80, 81 right around
there when I started watching.
We've had
the fucking guy.
Yeah.
Just never get the fucking guy.
I just don't understand.
Yeah.
You know,
we suck.
We suck it sucking at the
right time it seems so,
I dunno, it's going to be a,
uh, I don't know. But they,
but we do have the right coach.
So, I dunno, settling in,
settling into another fucking season.
We'll see how it goes. You know,
it looks like Montreal makes him
great fucking moves. Prices back.
Healthy is health. I don't
know. We'll see. We'll see.
I'm taking a hanging around tomorrow
night and going to that predators.
A penguins game with, uh, with Bart.
So if you're going down there,
maybe I'll see you down.
They get to see [inaudible] and all
that shit could be a good fucking time.
So I don't know how much fucking
time I've done here. Let me,
let me read a little
advertising. Um, all right,
lift everybody. You
know about Lyft, right?
Do you know about left?
Um,
it's that APP that gets you a
ride in minutes on demand 24,
seven for less than the cost of a cab.
Yeah.
Odd of, fuck did they do that? Calves are
pretty cheap, aren't they? I don't know.
We gotta bite him.
Medallian maybe that's the fucking
overhead as opposed to just have some guy
getting, hey, I'll get in the car with you
if you tried Lyft. You know what I mean?
With lifts. You just download
the APP, request a driver,
and they show up in three and a half
minutes on average. That's really fast.
I don't get why they can
do that in taxis camp. Uh,
every Lyft driver is full, fully vetted
to that 10 points. Safety Standard.
Oh, I take it back. This isn't like Uber.
What you fucking get in with
the former serial killer ride?
Is there such a thing?
Okay.
He hasn't killed in awhile.
This d they actually, oh my God,
they actually do a background check.
I'm going to use this shit including
criminal and DMV background checks.
You know, you'll get around quick so
you know, you'll get around quickly.
And safety lift drivers
are rated after every ride.
So only the best stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting
into a filthy car with some creepy dude.
With Lyft, you can tip, uh, in the APP,
which obviously leads to happier drivers.
I mean,
nine out of 10 Lyft riders get a perfect
five star rating from the passengers.
It's just a better all around experience.
Bigger isn't always better lift.
Is it the biggest ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing
in the highest rated one. Um,
what they're talking about here is
quantity, quality over quantity. Um,
thanks to lift, you got an easy
way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bum a ride and you
never have to worry about parking.
A lot of people are actually getting
rid of their cars and relying on Lyft to
get around. And you know
what? I don't blame them.
Who is the I in that? Is that supposed
to be me? That's fucking nuts.
Maybe you could do it.
I Dunno.
You know what's weird is
what's great about Lyft? Yeah.
It gets all these drunk
drivers off the road,
but now everybody's texting and
driving and they're thinking,
well cause I'm sober. You know, it's a
fucking scary time up there. All right.
Right now, Lyft is offering our listeners
a special deal. Get three free rides,
up to $10 each.
That's up to a $30 value when you enter
the Promo Code Bill Burr B, I. L,L ,
B, u r are all one word. All capitals.
Just download the free Lyft app today
and enter the Promo Code Gilbert,
like I said, two seconds ago
when the payment section,
uh, you'll start with three,
three free rides up to $10 each,
and that's up to a $30 value.
That Promo Code Burr. Hey,
enter Promo code [inaudible]
all right. Net pay. Yeah man.
Uh, do you ever wonder
we're feeding your pet? Uh,
no. So it becomes a fat fuck.
I can kind of see it right?
Let's this gotta be a reason for this.
Sure.
Studies show feeding your pet the right
amount every day would help them live
longer.
But how do you know you're feeding your
pet the right amount of food each day?
Oh,
I see what to say.
Introducing hadn't at smart feed.
Oh my God.
These people have to advertise forever.
This is another great one. Once again,
if you missed it,
that's petnet smart.
Um,
the new smart phone.
Okay.
The fuck I just lost my place.
The new smartphone controls automatic
pet feeder that personalize your pets
daily calorie intake using their age,
weight,
activity level and food type.
With the pet net APP.
You can schedule and monitor your
pet's meals all from your smartphone,
meaning your pet is always fed
even when you're running late.
Stop worrying about feeding your pet
the wrong amount of food every day.
The petnet smart.
See Ya.
Okay,
well that's might be my favorite word
in the English language right now.
We'll feed the healthiest portions at
the right time every time automatically.
All right,
pets and the pet net.
Smart Feeder is the best way for you to
make sure you're feeding them the right
amount every day.
But these things are popular and since
the petnet smart feeder is produced in a
limited quantity each month, you need to
get yours before they sell out at shop.
Pet net.com/bird today and you get free
shipping to a personalized the way you
feed your pets with pet net.
Get pet net smart fee plus free
shipping when you go to shop.
Pet net.com/burr that shot pet
net.com/birth for the love of Christ.
Shop pet net dotcom.
Slash. Bar. All right.
What the fuck happened anymore?
These are there.
Okay.
You got two more.
Well,
I'm not reading those now and we can
give you a break from my fucking awful
reading out loud skills
or the lack thereof. Um,
so anyways, uh, I got myself
into standup special shape.
I'm going to keep fucking going
right through to thanksgiving.
Um, and as mentioned, hey,
I'm going to be doing a, um,
uh, a benefit. The Cam Neely, uh,
Dennis leary benefit, uh, in
Boston. I believe that Saturday,
November 12th tickets are on sale
and about this time next month,
this time next month,
the fifth annual Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit will be going down again.
I'll be announcing the lineup,
uh, in about three weeks.
Um, I know I got a spot coming up on
Conan O'brien, I think on November 9th.
And uh, one of the promotional
things is going to be that. And a,
it's one of my favorite
things of the year. Um,
I get to see all these comics that
always headlines, so I never see them.
And so it's become like this sort of
stand up comedy like fucking high school
reunion thing. I always get to
see his mom and Patrice is family.
It's just a,
it really is a fucking great event and a
this year I think I'm actually going to
do a little more press on it because
at first I never did any press.
It's a long story.
MMM.
As to why I didn't,
I didn't because I was pissed basically
because the first year we were going to
have a benefit in the industry was going
to put it together and it was all set
to come together. All right. And
then all of a sudden it went away,
which is an expression in the
entertainment business. What happened way?
I thought I was doing that
thing. I went away, it went away.
Like what the fuck does that mean?
Um,
and uh,
I'm not going to tell you the reasons
why it went away, but it was infuriating.
So I just said,
fuck this.
Um, and whatever. I
got help with the right people.
And uh,
I was so pissed that it went away the
first time that I was like, fuck this,
we don't need to advertise. And I
got Colin Quinn, I got Jim Norton,
I got opie and Anthony behind this bucket
thing. And I thought it was a great,
like sort of tribute in a way to Patrice
that his name alone would sell out
this, this theater, you know, the
love that people had and all of that.
And he was always like underground,
you know,
all these people that were
getting accolades, like,
oh my God, she's the best.
He's the beds and blah, blah, blah.
And everybody who was doing
it knew he was the best.
So I thought it was kind
of a cool way to do it.
But now what I'm seeing is
now that he's been gone,
unfortunately coming up on five years,
I think it's important that, uh,
you know, to get his name out
there and stuff like that.
So I'm just going to maybe do a little
bit of press this time around and um,
tell some stories and that
type of stuff about, you know,
how fucking truly amazing that guy was.
So before the tickets even go on sale,
once again, I want to thank
everybody. Um, you know, this, we,
there's people that we meet after the
show that have come almost every year.
A few people have come every single year.
Um,
and like other than paying for
the a to rent the place out,
mmm.
All the proceeds,
it's gone to his family and they've
been able to do wonderful things.
Everything from sending a his
stepdaughter to private school and, um,
you know,
his mother has as a nice place to live
and she doesn't have to worry about
anything. So like, you know, and it's just
one of those things like I always hated,
I always hate it when somebody passed and
then you do like one benefit for their
surviving family members and everything.
It's like, well, here you go.
Here's this sack of money. Try to make
this last for another fucking 40 years.
Um, you know, so I don't
know. That's, that's like,
that's a big fucking deal.
So anyways, anyways, um,
I think I'm about all talked out.
MMM.
I think I've done a half hour.
I have no fucking idea.
If I haven't done a half hour,
I'm just going to speak to you.
The way that they did the credit card
people speak to you. It's just like, well,
I'm sorry you confused. They said that
to me. It's like I'm not confused.
I'm telling you what you told me. Well,
I'm sorry. It's like you're not sorry.
Stop saying you're sorry.
I just started saying it back to her.
It's like you're literally
like talking to a robot. I go,
I'm sorry that your sorry that. I'm sorry.
Then I'm confused even though I'm not,
but maybe you are, but you're not going
to take responsibility for that. You know,
I was really off my game.
I should've like just asks to
speak to somebody above them.
Um,
I dunno.
Let me just read the last advertising
because evidently I got to spend the next
fucking hour trying to figure out how
to apply for a credit card online,
but it's, which I'm sure there's
no fucking safety risk there.
Probably had to go to some website and
fucking type in my social security number
and all that shit. Fuck that. Fuck
that. We should just go back to trading.
You know what I mean? You know, back
in the day when someone come to town,
and so it'd be like, Hey, is
that a turnip? And you'd be
like, wow, yes, yes it is.
It's like you want a pair of
boots and you'd be like, yeah,
I'd love a pair of boots gimme for
turnips. Ah Man, I can't give you that.
That's to turnips a boot.
Come on. All right, let me,
let me give about three and be that
guy. I'll give you three. You know,
these are big fucking
terms, by the way. Um,
if people's diets with very limited too.
So I think it just showed up with a
fucking turnip. Everybody was excited,
you know what I mean? So if he just
made that a little more modern,
it'd be like, hey man, is that an iPhone?
Yeah. All right, I'll give you my hoodie.
You want a hooded sweatshirt with
whatever may or may not be in the front
pockets, you know, you know,
there's some degenerate gambler that would
try to take that fucking what if it's
some good man? Um, anyways.
All right. Jesus Christ. Phil,
just read the fucking last two and put
this podcast out of its fucking misery.
I don't think I've ever been less
funny on a fucking podcast, you know?
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm like such a self sabotaging cons.
I've got this big coming up.
I
wasn't supposed to drink this week.
I fucking drank every night.
I smoked for fucking cigars.
I stayed out til three in the morning.
I was hanging out with Trump supporters.
I was hanging out with cigars.
Fucking people, you know, always I know.
I realized was I should have
hung out with Hillary supporters.
They would have been more fun to
annoyed because Trump supporters,
they don't give a fuck. They're all
knees and elbows. You know what I mean?
They're too dumb to get
fucking like annoyed.
I wasn't even trying to do it. Actually
make great people down there that night,
but like the Hillary people are
just, oh, that would have been fun.
It's fun because you can, you can, you
can kick them on two different levels.
You can,
you can annoy them politically.
And then you can also be like
chauvinistically, incest, sexist.
You can just throw all of that in.
Um,
which always goes back to that fucking
prank I wanted to do with Patrice O'Neal
and anybody out there can
steal this if you want to. Um,
and the late nineties when we would
struggle and no one knew who the fuck we
were, I came so close to convincing him
to do it. And then at the last second,
he didn't want to do it.
We were going to go on to judge Judy
and either he was going to sue
me or I was going to sue him.
And it didn't matter because whoever won,
like whatever you need,
if they made him pay me, I just give him
the fucking money back or vice versa.
But we were going to go on there and we
would just going to try to see how mad
we could make her, you
know, and we would act dumb.
So that would feed into her fucking ego.
And the one thing that I knew I was
going to do but I didn't know if I could
keep a straight face was when she yelled
at me at one point I supposed to be
like,
Hey Ladi Ladi Ladi ladi like that alone,
she would have blown a fucking gasket and
as long as they acted like dumb enough.
Um, I dunno cause it was like the height
of those judge shows and just annoyed me
how they were always grand standing,
yelling at these fucking
simpletons you know,
like they were the smartest person
on the planet. It's like, you know,
if you were really smart and he
probably still be a judge when you,
well actually maybe they are smart
cause then they got out of the judicial
system and they got their
own fucking judge show.
But then that that would meet,
that would mean that fucking Dr Phil is
really smart, which I'm sure he is due.
Dr Phil, I swear to God, doesn't
he look like he strangles puppies?
He just seems like he has like
the most horrific fucking temper.
Like, he should have been one of those,
like if he ever got like an acting Gig,
like he would be like a great,
like a number sling blade when, uh,
in the end when he's in that home,
that insane asylum and that fucking Weirdo
I was talking to him, he would have,
he would have been
great. Is that, you know,
like I look at that guy and
I swear to God, like I just,
he probably does that Phil Spector's shit.
Remember his poor woman is, you know,
he probably sticks a gun in her mouth,
you know, cause they're on a ketchup. Um,
that's what he strikes me. I see.
He looks like a dirty cop to me.
Um, anyway, there was a little
comedy. All right. All right,
let's read the last few of these.
All right. Simply safe. Oh fuck.
I almost forgot to tell you
guys this. So I, you know,
I'm just sick of all the areas that I am,
that I'm in on the Internet.
I go to the same fucking four websites
and one of them I just got boxed out of,
one of them was Facebook.
I went to change my password and they
said his first security purposes,
we, we've blocked your account, we
just need some information out of you.
So we know what shoe
when they tried to get,
they tried to get me to give them that
my passport or my birth certificate.
That's like, dude, you're a social media
site. I'm not giving you this stuff.
Go Fuck Yourself. So now I'm officially
off Facebook. Um, I don't know how to get,
but maybe back in the day we changed your
password. They just sent you an email.
That was it.
And now they're trying,
they just keep trying to get
more information out of you.
Like if you notice this new thing,
if you valet a car,
like they go a just text us,
just text this number off your cell phone.
So then they get you cell phone number.
Um, do they have your name though?
I Dunno. I just don't want people
have my fucking phone up. Like,
I wish there would be a big backlash to
this shit where, you know, when they,
you walk into a rental car and they like,
how did you hear about us?
And people like, well, I was
talking to my mother, you know,
where does your mother live? Can we have
a phone number? What's your address?
And they will ask and ask
and ask until you go, hey,
I don't think that's any of your fucking
business. And then they go, okay.
And then you realize,
wait a minute.
So those other five things that I
just gave you, that was optional toe.
MMM.
But anyways, yeah, I'm not
on a, so I got sick of it
and uh,
on the same four or five websites,
I don't want it to Facebook.
I go onto youtube,
I'd be on Twitter
and, um, you know, football
and hockey season, nfl.com,
nhl.com and then one of three
porn sites when I'm on the road.
Right.
So Facebook has gone,
I'm done with Internet porn. I've, I've
tried quitting this, like heroin, like 50.
Like how do you not watch fucking
hot chicks banging? I mean I just,
how do you not fucking watch it? I never
should have opened that Pandora's box.
So anyways,
I'm trying to stay away from that.
So then I was thinking I need some new
fucking websites here, new places to go.
So I just looked up the top
20 in all of them. You know,
it was like Google,
youtube,
half of the ones where I was on except
the number three one. I went on that one,
it was some fucking website from China.
So I've actually been on their website
so I'm sure they stole a bunch of Shit
from me or I'm on some
sort of watch list now.
So my question do you guys is if you
know any decent like websites that just,
I know that it has some cool content
or whatever that I can go to cause I'm,
I dunno, I'm Kinda sick are
the ones that I'm going,
well I was going to say was I went
down this rabbit hole when, uh,
I was on youtube,
like I never got into punk music and I
just keep hearing like more and more like
a, like as deep as I went was like
butthole surfers, like rancid.
Um, I, I like those guys that like
crossed over, you know what I mean?
Um, into the mainstream, which I'm sure
all punk rockers are saying, but who's,
who's gonna fucking punk?
These people are applying now and this
isn't jazz and that's not real fucking
country music and all your fuck you
when you're the posters on your wall.
All right, I'm new to this shit. So, um,
I just went down this rabbit hole and
I was just kind of like, well, what's,
what's hardcore punk versus
regular punk, you know. Um,
and then,
you know,
I was watching this interview with like
one of the guitarists and rancid and he
brought up,
uh,
that he liked oi music. Like, Oh, why?
And I'm like, what the fuck is that?
And it was a kind of punk music. I
was like, I never heard of that shit.
And then I just looked it up and uh,
and I found all these fucking bands and
then it just went down this fucking,
I dunno, I lost like three
hours of my life. See,
I find this band a sham 69,
and they were playing live and do their
front man is fucking unbelievable.
Like I was watching this guy going like
this guy should be considered one of the
great front men through one
song. I was like, I would,
I would love to Bennett that fucking
show his energy was ridiculous.
Right.
And then I just started reading about
them and I might fuck this up cause I read
about a bunch of different bands,
but there was like,
I guess with them that style and
music for whatever they drew in,
like soccer fans or whatever.
Like the hooligans and then there was
some neo Nazis there and then they were
all fighting with each other.
And there was one night,
there was some big fucking brawl at one
of their shows and it was so bad at the
kind of almost like killed their career.
I am,
it might've been that band or something.
I definitely recommend like just going
on youtube and looking up all that shit
cause so much stuff that
I didn't understand about
punk music cause so many of
the punk singers could not fucking sing.
And it just sounded like angry karaoke
to me, like played through a fucking,
not like, it didn't sound
like it was in stereo. Um,
but all of a sudden now,
those sounds of like appealing to me.
So I'm kind of gravitating towards it.
So there's this famous picture
of Sid Sid vicious and he has a,
yeah,
he has a,
a swastika on his shirt.
So I stay used to always make me stay
away from the sex pistols going like,
oh man, that they will, they will,
they will like that, you know,
he's symmetric and all
of this type of shit.
White supremacists and
from what I was reading,
this is so fucked up.
It's kind of funny though,
was it had nothing really to do with the,
what it had to do was their parents who
are part of the World War II generation,
I guess rather than saying to the
children of that generation, you know,
we used to walk to school uphill
both ways. They used to say like,
I don't want to hit you a bitch.
And we defeated Hitler. Uh,
we won World War II when they were
like rubbing it in their face. Like,
what the fuck did you ever do when
they got sick of it? So they basically,
it's like if you hate your dad and he's
a red sox fan, you buy a Yankee hat.
So like they hated their fucking
world war two when his parents,
I guess so their reaction is that
they wore the fucking German shit.
Um,
but then what that inadvertently did is
it started to drawn out these neonazis
out to the show. It was, it was
fucking fascinating, you know,
that plaid that they were,
I always saw that and they put
all the pins and shit through it.
I guess that that was actually
someone in the royal family,
like that was their colors or whatever.
So then they took that.
So some of this shit,
they either did the exact opposite and,
or they just took from the aristocratic,
the people in power and uh,
put their own fucking twist on it
just to piss him off. And um, I dunno,
but the one band that, that I came across
that I really fucking lights was, uh,
was sham 69 and I'm particularly
those borstal breakout and a hurry up.
Harry was a cool fucking
song. And uh, I don't know.
I've tried like 900 times.
I know I missed out on black flag and
a bad brains and all of that shit.
I would really like, like somebody
gives me an entry level band,
like how are you can work my
way down from like, you know,
the green day level that I'm at,
not disrespect and green day cause I
think they're a great fucking band,
but I understand that they're super
successful and they've made a ton of money
so they're automatically not a
part of that scene anymore. Right.
Is that how it fucking works? I
don't fucking know. Anyways. Um,
I got my big shows tomorrow night.
I'm going to read these
last two advertising's
advertisements and that's going
to be it. And then, uh,
I'm going to find a sports bar a night
and I'm going to watch my Bruins is we
fucking mediocre way or our way through
another fucking season. You know,
I'm glad we reassigned Marshawn,
man.
I'm surprised we didn't fucking lose him
if we must have something good coming
down the pike if he stayed.
Uh,
cause that guy had an unbelievable season
and I missed the World Cup of hockey,
but they were saying in the hockey news
that he very easily could have been the
fucking MVP of the thing. So I'm glad.
I'm glad we got it. That guy. Um,
I hope some of these
prospects fucking pan out
posture knock these like 58
different ways to pronounce that guy.
Maybe he'll blossom into a, I just
want somebody scoring 50, right?
That take that guy that you just have to
fuck the other team just has to fucking
prepare for, you know what I mean? Like,
uh, like s Ovechkin level fucking guy.
We got it built. All
right? Simply, simply safe.
Thousands of people seeking home get
ripped off every day.
And the home security industry wants
you to believe it's your only option.
They've got hoards of salesmen out there
trying to scare you into signing one of
their longterm contracts. He gets stuck
writing huge checks month after month,
no way out.
It's robbery by contract and it
can cost you thousands, thousands.
But there's a better way to protect
your home. Simply safe home security.
Simply safe has no contracts,
none.
You'll get award winning 24 seven
protection named best in the industry,
security professionals watching,
ready to instantly send the police.
And it's just 1499 per month.
That's less than half of
what most companies charge.
Protect your home and this the smart way.
Protect your call to action.
Protect your home the smart way.
I just fucking said that.
Visit simply safe bird.com go right now.
And you'll also get free shipping on
your order and a free key chain remote
where $25 and it takes only a minute.
That's simply safe.
bird.com simply faith bird.com you know
I got a free key chain when I bought my
car. Fucking thing broke. Then like, uh,
like two days of me having the God
damn thing. Um, alright. Helix.
Helux you're unique.
You don't walk like Debbie one talk like
everyone else or asleep like everyone
else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because a truly custom customized mattress
will cost you five to 10,000 bucks.
Is that true? Until now? Go to helix,
sleep.com answers a few simple questions
and they'll run a three d biochemical
model of your body through the proprietary
algorithms they developed with the
help of the world's leading
ergonomics and biomechanics experts.
You do it. If they work with
fucking grass, that was a
fancy name for landscaping.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't know
what that meant. Uh, the result,
the most comfortable mattress
you've ever slept on.
Helix customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality.
And for couples, they customize
each side of the mattress. Oh,
I thought they wanted you to lay on
top of each other. So when you fucking,
it's still comfortable. You
never know. Maybe they do.
Now how do you guys usually do it?
Is She writing you?
Are you on top of her as it doggy style?
Cause if that's the case,
then we need to imprints for
knees and hands. And for couples,
they customize each side of the mattress.
Your mattress arrives at your door and
about a week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from
Gq magazine to Forbes,
they're all talking about helic sleep.
You have 100 nights to try it out and if
you don't love it, they'll pick it up.
Grouse gross.
They'll pick it up for free.
How thick of the gloves.
You know what?
They'd probably use those barbecue
pit gloves, welder gloves,
and they give you 100% refund.
No questions asked. Go to hell.
He sleep.com/burn and
get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/bar
hey healthy sleep.com/burn
you know what they probably
do with those mattresses?
I bet they bring them to Cuba for people.
Want to fucking try and come over here.
You know,
cause they always take a mattress.
Okay.
Maybe they sell it to them. You know,
try to get a little bit of money back.
I have no idea. All I know is this
is the end of the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Please enjoy the music is we will now
be playing 30 minutes of greatest hits
from a podcast gone by in a month.
That isn't this one or maybe it is.
I have no fucking idea.
I apologize for the click sound
and now I have to shut it off.
Oh, for fuck's sakes. Come on. All
right. That's it. All right guys.
You have a nice weekend.
You can't.
MMM,
I'm warming up.
I watched that fucker game yesterday
and we lost and Nia was going to go see
lady Gaga last night and at the
last second, her friend bailed.
Actually the day before her friend
bailed. So she goes, do you want to go?
Would you go with me? And I was just
like, yeah, I'll fucking go to that.
I'll go to it. You know, I'm a comedian.
I need to know what the fuck's
going on in pop culture.
I will go to this stuff and I will
go to this thing. And she goes,
do you realize how funny is it going
to be if somebody who listens to your
podcast is at that thing and sees
you at that? And I said, yeah,
it's going to be fucking hilarious.
So I went down there and get ready to see,
you know, no, let, let's, let's tell
this in chronological ori water.
I'm watching the Patriots game over
a buddy of mine's house and I'm just
pounding beers.
I Dunno why I bought a 12 pack.
They were set up and I just felt like I
had to knock them all down and I think,
I think I had at least
seven of them if not eight.
I somebody else was digging into them too.
I can't fucking remember.
You don't one of those things where
you're not really totally hammered but you
forget your sunglasses.
You don't like that kind of level drunk.
So now I got to race home and uh,
you know, shut myself off from the
third quarter just like I'm at the game.
I just start drinking waters and eating
fucking chicken wings and shit and a
sober up jump in the car, drive
home, put on a shirt. Oh wait, no,
we took a cab.
That's right.
We ended up taking a cab over to staples
center and we miss the opening act,
which I'm like bonus,
cause I know I'm not going to like them.
And we come fucking walking into the
staple center ad right as the show starts.
And Lady Gaga comes out of a fake castle
on a horse and starts walking around
the arena and you only do that big thing.
Now they got like the big fucking half
a semi circle loop with a bunch of
fucking raven kids in the middle of it.
And um,
that's what started it off. And then
she sang one of her songs, it then,
uh,
then she went back into the castle and
then all of a sudden it looked like it
was a Turkey with its legs spread.
And uh,
she came out of the vagina that unzipped
it and came out of that, you know?
Yeah.
And then sang another fucking song,
you know, bunch of shredded gay guys,
old five, six, seven, eight,
all at the same fucking time.
And then she just starts spewing
this fucking self-help Horse Shit.
Okay.
You know, doing that stupid dramatic
pause to milk the crowd. She says like,
you know,
it's great to be here today. Lot.
They're Angelus. There is like
society.
Okay. The message out there for
anyone who's ever felt different,
if you feel different, no, they
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
All this fucking bullshit about being,
it was literally like,
it was like gay spinal tap
and it was honestly,
it was a terrible fucking show.
Okay,
terrible show. The fucking dancing was
terrible. She can sing, but she stinks.
It dancing. She's on a fucking
horse. She comes out of a vagina.
How many times has that been done? Why
did you come out of the vagina? Lady Gaga?
Let me guess.
This album was a rebirth for you.
You fucking hack ripping off
Madonna right left. First of all,
she's got that one song that I've,
I don't know what Madonna's song is.
I never know I, whenever I hear it, I
start singing the other Madonna's song,
right?
She's ripping off Madonna right down.
She had a black Jesus and the
crowds eating it up. And I'll,
and at first I'm like, you
gotta be fucking, she's
doing the black Jesus thing,
like a prayer. Am I the only gun? I looked
around, I was like, Oh my God, I'm old.
I'm old,
I'm fucking old and I'm there and all I
want to do is just start trashing. Yes.
I want to start heckling,
which I did a couple of times and Nia
just gave me the look and I was like,
I can't ruin this for her.
She was going to go here with somebody
else who's going to be waving glow sticks
and I agreed to come here.
I can't be a cunt. So, um,
I'm not glad you guys sat down
after the first fucking song.
And uh,
it was really difficult to listen to.
It was really fucking annoying.
Way More knowing that I
thought I was going to be,
I thought that was gonna be all right.
You know,
it's still going to be on some level.
Appreciate it. This is pop shit.
I can try to come here and
enjoy this shit. And it was,
it just really wasn't a good show.
I can't fucking,
okay.
Oh with the stupid dramatic pauses.
Why does singers always have to look up
in the air halfway through a sentence
and just get another applause break.
I saw a band the other night in this
little fucking club and the guy was doing
that. He was like, you know,
this is the first time.
Then he looks up to ceiling
and it's just dead silence.
And then the crowd always
gives into the fucking silence.
I don't know if they feel uncomfortable
with and they just feel they have to
fill it up by going woo.
And then the guy finishes the sentence
that we'd been in Los Angeles in three
years. It's like, why couldn't
you just complete that sentence?
Why couldn't you just go, hey, you know,
this is the first time we've been in Los
Angeles for La for like three years and
we're happy to be back cause
you guys are great feds.
You could do that and like fucking,
what was that?
How long did it take me to say that? 3.5
seconds. It takes him like 30 seconds.
Okay.
Los Angeles is a city.
Yeah.
That's on the west coast of
this country and you know,
oh was fucking horrible. So
anyways, Lady Gaga is on stage.
I can't believe I have this fucking
story. I feel like I dreamed it. Um,
okay.
She just goes, she's finishes another
one, her fucking horseshit songs.
I think at that point she was like
dry humping a Yak to protest, uh,
some sort of Middle Eastern thing.
I don't know what the fuck was going on.
And by the way,
her drama was the shit and I really
would have enjoyed watching him,
but he appeared to be in the dungeon
section inside the fucking castle.
Cause God forbid there's somebody else
out on the fucking stage taken away from
your fucking horse shit. Oh
my God. And then she has,
she had two plants in the crowd
to clear fucking plant.
She calls some fucking young gay kid
on the crowd and tells him it's okay.
And the kid starts fucking cause like,
how did you get his number?
When did you get his number?
How do they have a miked up?
How can I hear this guy clear as fucking
day talking into a fucking cell phone
that's on through the roof of
the staple center to outer space,
back down to the fucking through the
roof again to lady Gaga who's got drapes
around her fucking head.
Right. Crowds eat it up like,
oh my God, she's a sate look
at her reaching out. Right.
And then the worst part was she sitting
there dancing around and she's only a
little bit better dancer than I am and
I'm fucking horrific. So she's up there.
Yeah.
Um,
and then she goes,
where's that guy with the green hair and
the crowd get up on the stage, you know,
cause she's so down to earth and the dude,
the green hair dude gets up on the
fucking stage. Shortlists shredded, right.
So right there, you know, it's a plant,
although there were a lot of gay guys
there and gay guys are always fucking
shredded. So I'll give him
the benefit of doubt on that.
So the shirtless fucking shredded
dude with the green hair gets on,
runs up the runway,
doing his best to act like he's shocked.
Okay.
And then they go into this fucking
dance routine and this dude knows,
okay,
every fucking move right down to when
to leave with the other dancers and walk
into the castle. It's like, why
is he going into the castle?
I thought he was just to some random
guy you pulled out of the fucking crowd.
Should he go back to his God damn seat?
How much of a grumpy contem I
that I'm really ripping the shit.
If I was fucking I, I gotta
tell you I was really, yeah,
I was really disappointed.
I felt like I put myself in the,
in the head space where I could enjoy
this. I was already seven beers in.
I grabbed a little bit.
I'm Mcdonald's on the way in,
had a quarter pounder with cheese, French
fries. I'm like, all right, let's see. Uh,
let's see this fucking, let's
see this. I know she can sing,
so it should be halfway
decent. Didn't it just was, oh,
and in the songs and then just
sitting there with fucking,
every time drapes around her face.
It's like,
when are you just going to
accept your nose? We get it.
You don't like your nose but you're
afraid to get a nose job cause you think
it's going to change the
sound of your voice just well,
when are you get you sitting there
telling all these young gay kids,
it's okay that they're different.
It is.
You can't even accept your face walking
around like that chick from the ring.
Yeah.
Hair all in your God damn face.
Fucking awful.
Yeah.
If finished it every song and then she
just sit there all wrapped and drapes in
the being only
breathing into the mic,
which was super fucking annoying.
Then she was like,
I hope you guys are
having a good time tonight
cause if you're not,
I don't give a fuck.
I said, I don't give a fuck,
fuck. And whole crowd goes nuts.
Then she proceeds to give a fucking
speech about how much she doesn't give a
fuck.
Okay.
Goes over to another shredded gay
guy. Fucking backup dancer. You know,
hey fucking soliloquy. Do you, do you give
a fuck? He's like, I don't give a fuck.
I think,
I think that's when I heckled and I got
my first dirty look from Dhea because
it's literally like, you know,
if you don't give a fuck,
get on with the not giving
a fuck, why would you stop
and give a speech? You know,
that's something I've learned in life is
if you don't give a fuck, you just, you,
you, you don't say you don't give a fuck.
If you don't give a fuck other people,
they recognize it and they say it for you.
Hey Dude, you know, you know that kid,
uh, you know, like Kid Mike. Yeah, yeah,
I'd do that kid that he doesn't
give a fuck seriously, that cute.
And then you tell the fucking story. But
Mike isn't walking around gone, you know,
telling everybody that
he doesn't give a fuck.
She clearly gives a fuck.
She gives a fuck how she looks.
I don't think she likes the way she looks.
And I think that that's why she fucking
walking around with an Afghan or fucking,
I don't know what you call it,
upholstery. Oliver fucking face.
I Dunno. Whatever will should, I just
enjoyed that. They, they, they, they,
I don't know if with the fucking,
I dunno what I was really, I
mean, as dumb as this sounds,
I went there with some sort of
expectations and I just, you know,
I thought the drama was the best
part of the fucking show. And he was,
he was in a castle and I couldn't
fucking see him granted his,
his drum strix with lit up so I could
seek some of this shit that he was doing.
But uh, I dunno. And then
there was some sort of,
there was some sort of story going on.
I felt like they were like workshopping
a musical and they didn't really have
the full story. They just kept
being this face that would glow up.
And it was lady Gaga is,
and she would just be speaking monotone,
like she was some sort of Zombie,
which I guess was supposed to
give it some sort of depth.
Can you guys believe that if somebody's
44 going to be 45 is wasting this much
time talking about how I was disappointed
at a lady Gaga concert as if that
fucking show in any shape or form was
designed to appeal to some fucking
redheaded cont like
make, you know, whatever.
I had to get that out because there's a
chance in the end might be coming down
to the podcast and I did a real good
job not taking the piss out of that show
when I was there and not ruining
it for, but, uh, anyways,
fucking, it was really
bad. You know what I mean?
Even Madonna concerts back
in the fucking day. Oh,
that was another thing that she fucking
said she was going like, you know,
when I started out, uh, dramatic pause,
people didn't think that I could
bring the underground gay scene to the
mainstream. You know, it's like,
why are you ignoring Madonna?
Didn't Madonna do that like 20 years ago?
Then the village people kind of start it.
You know what's funny about
like it was so, it was,
that shit was so fucking
underground in the 70s,
right into the 80s that morons like,
didn't know that like half the people
you were listening to were gay. Yeah. No.
Even though like you'd be listening
to a band called Queen and the guy's
prancing around.
Yeah.
In his, in fucking why don't know
what the diapers, adult diapers,
I don't know what he was doing walking
around barefoot. You still like the music?
You didn't, you still in? No,
I watched the other day I was
watching this Judas priest concert.
Uh,
I forget where the fuck they were.
It was like in the early eighties
and Rob Halford is coming out
like in like literally a king,
like
sn,
this s and m outfit
and he had no fucking idea.
MMM.
I know. There's like 20 guys like
that. It was still underground,
but like that Madonna's shit when
she know the El Ed Vogan crap.
That was like 20, almost 25 years
at this point. So I don't know.
I think that's just what it is.
I think I'm just an old fucking guy.
And I imagine when I was watching
whatever the fuck I was watching,
they were all going through.
Zeplin did this like 15 years ago as I'm
sitting there freaking out watching a
band called Cinderella.
I think that was the point of it.
No offense to lady Gaga fans.
I think I just realized how
fucking old day was all right.
And I just watched my team loses.
[inaudible]
Hey, what's going on? It's bill.
And this is the Monday morning podcast
for the week of October something.
What is it, the 20th? I
believe it's the 20th. Um,
I'm actually in Phoenix
international airport connecting,
trying to get back to la after a A.
I had a great weekend out in Austin,
Texas at the Cap City comedy club and I
want to thank everybody who came out to
my shows. Crowds were ridiculous.
Just uh, just awesome crowds.
I wasn't one ass told him
the whole week. Um, I dunno.
Definitely, definitely going
to be coming back. Um, Ellen,
thanks to Dudley and Bob to the radio
show that let me pour myself out the
entire week. So I could get some
fannies in the seats. And, um,
and with that, here's the podcast at
that beginning stunk something like,
I, I've just lost an election. I want to
thank everybody who helped me out and,
uh, this isn't over. We're going to
regroup and we're going to be book.
Um, what the fuck? So anyways, as many,
you know, I'm a huge fan of all Boston
sports growing up outside the city.
And last night my red sox lost
game seven to the, uh, the devil,
the race of the fuck they call themselves
now because those are the devil to
mean. Can somebody from Tampa please
explain to me why you dropped devil,
devil rays, the name of
a sting ray. You know,
did some sting rays get together
and find it offensive? Um,
anyways, uh, congratulations.
Spelled uh, the,
the race fans keep wanting to say
devil rays, uh, you know, definitely.
What a better team. Um, I
dunno man, you guys would just,
just, just fucking, just too
good. You were just too good.
Pitching was ridiculous.
You got a bunch of young studs
on there and you know what?
I hope you can hold onto
them for when rich as teams,
like the red sox start buying people up
because that's what the fuck is wrong
with baseball because you
waited long enough down there.
You should have a good team.
You should have it for a while.
Much as it's going to stop. Fuck
that. We'll be back next year. Um,
but anyways, you know something. Yeah,
this is great. You guys got a great team.
But you know when you do have to get rid
of, you don't have to, just a suggestion.
Uh,
the fucking cow bells.
That was really a, I don't know. You know,
I was willing to look the other way that
every time I saw the d raise on TV for
the last fucking 10 years,
there was eight people in the crowd and
now all of a sudden you guys are good
and everybody shows up.
I was willing to look the other way,
cause I'm not gonna lie to you.
I didn't want yourself the game for
about eight years until last year.
So everybody does that.
But the cow bells,
I've nothing screams expansion
team like noise makers.
You know what I mean? It's
just like, you know what,
our fans are so fucking lame that
even when this place is sold out,
we have to give them noisemakers
like it's fucking new years.
You know what I mean?
And it really doesn't hurt the other team.
It's sort of a noise.
Everybody you notice last night you're
starting pitcher was wearing earplugs.
I never
just as a sports fan,
I don't understand like how the UN,
I understand annoying the batter
with the fucking cow bells,
but the picture can hear it too. No
one wants to hear that. You know?
They really don't.
But you know what?
I'll give you a pass because
you were an expansion team.
The team that I will not give a pass to
is the California angels of Anaheim and
just north of San Diego,
but fucking south of Sacramento.
Whatever they call themselves with
those funders sticks. I don't know.
It's just really gay.
You know,
people should know you're in the stands
just because of you vocally when you
have to, you know. I mean, how did
that work out there, Angel Fan?
Did you literally get down on your knees
and below those things up yourself?
I end up being a bit of a jerk and it
has nothing to do with the socks loosen.
And it actually has to do with the fact
that I stuck around Texas for an extra
day because,
uh,
I drove over to Houston and went
to a fucking Texans game by myself.
It's just pathetic. I
Dunno. I got this OCD thing.
I got to go to every fucking team stadium
and I think I'm over it cause I was
really sitting there and the Holiday
Inn last night thinking, you know,
I could've been home right now,
but I didn't because I
decided to stay an extra day,
blow a couple of hundred bucks and watch
the Houston Texans play the Detroit
lions because everybody knows what a
fucking pivotal game that is in the middle
of October. What a moron.
Um, so anyway, hey,
let's start a new topic on the
podcast and knowing things in sports.
I'm going to start it off. Okay. I
already trashed, sorted, trashed.
I definitely trust the
angel fence, but, uh,
I'm gonna say noisemakers I'm
going to start off like that.
I think they're fucking stupid or
unnecessary and they make your fans look
amateurish. You know what I'm
saying? Um, but just to be fair,
I will throw my own team under the
bus because I love the red sox.
I love their fans,
but when they start singing sweet
Caroline during the seventh inning,
Eh, uh, I dunno,
I just want the green monster to
fall on every person who's singing.
I would just like to gather
up everyone in the crowd,
make them stand under the green monster
and then somehow push it over on top of
them. And you know what
I'm actually going to say,
I think that's worse than noisemakers
the singing of that awful song.
The song is so bad to begin with. And
then when the whole crowd goes boom, boom,
boom, it just really makes me want
to slit my wrist. Uh, what else?
What other ones
the fuck else bugs me.
I'd say the Yankees when they do that,
when the,
the grounds crew dancers to why MCA,
which was cute at first,
but it wasn't not like a big thing when
disco came back in the late nineties for
half a second. Uh, it's kind of over.
So why don't you pick a bad eighties
heavy metal to like rock me like a
hurricane or whatever. I Dunno. I got
fucking nothing. I got nothing this week.
You know what I got?
I got exactly what my cell phone has.
They got one bar right now.
It's exactly what I have.
So I don't want to get on with the,
uh, the questions for the week. Um,
and the underrated over rate and all that.
If you knew him like podcast,
this is what I do. I babble
in airports and um, Oh hey,
you know what I just did about
five minutes ago when I was in, um,
I hate when people do that. Did you hear
that? The only security guys were fine.
They have their walkie talkie and
they got it turned down to 10.
So you can't even hear what
they're saying. The Guy, he
can't even understand it.
He just walks by and here
it's like I got it.
Your important people need to
know where you are at all times,
bunch to turn it down to eight
for the rest of us. So anyways,
I was dining in the flux man
and place tab or nothing.
They'll Tequila airport and Mexican food,
which is some of the fattest
Mexican food that you can have.
I think because it's a sort of fast
food and it's made by white people. So
white people, the makers
of Mcdonald's. So anyways,
I'm in there and there's some fucking
asshole at the bar talking unbelievably
loud on his cell phone.
And I do what I usually do.
I rather than just addressing the guy,
I go passive aggressive.
First thing I do is I just let a
couple of Jesus Christ shut up,
you know, kind of do that. And you know,
or if he's, if he's going like, yeah,
yeah, yeah, I'll kind of go, yeah,
I'll do one Yaffe really loud.
And I was sitting there going like,
why don't I just tell him the guy that
he's fucking yelling and I'm thinking
because I'm an angry person and I'll
sound like a dick and I might end up
getting into a fistfight.
And then I started thinking to myself,
this guy is not going to be,
what was the last time you saw a
fist fight in a fucking airport?
I gotta be honest with you. I've
never seen it. Okay. Most, you know,
I've been reading about anger.
If most of anger comes when someone,
when you're in a position and you feel
powerless. So in my head I was like,
I'm powerless to do anything about this
situation because I don't want to get
your fist fight cause I'm gonna lose
either way. You know what I mean?
Once you get past a certain age,
you're going to lose. It's either a,
you get your ass kicked, you know what
I mean? And you standing up in some,
you know, you know the paper
that goes around a straw. Yeah.
It's like stuck to the back of your head.
You're going to suffer that all,
you're going to fucking win and
then you're going to get sued.
I think that's why adults don't fight.
It's,
it's the double whammy of the
possibility of losing and getting sued.
It's kind of sick of myself.
Like,
why don't you just not say
it like a fucking asshole,
right. Just do it that way. So
that's what I did. I just said, hey,
any kind of looked over. I
just said, I said, you get
kind of shouting. I said, Oh,
I'm sorry. Nine. He dropped it down to a
respectable Tom. And I was like, I'll see.
There you go.
See I do that.
I always invented my head and I'm going
to get the shit kicked out. And they,
cause I grew up and I had five brothers,
four brothers, five of us all together.
And uh,
that's the way it went down to my house.
Hey, could you turn the channel?
And next thing you know, you know,
it was like eight year old UFC and
the battle always went to the ground,
but the ground wasn't
sophisticated grappling.
It was more just headlocks and uh,
and hair pulling.
Um, actually no. Do we have a half an
hour? We just had a rule in our house.
If you could basically beat the living
shit out of somebody below the neck and
above the crutch, you could just
hammer somebody's torso. We, you know,
we've used to beat each other like, uh,
some of these assholes beat their wives.
You know, we don't want the
bruises to show. Um, okay,
I'm off the beaten track here. Let's,
let's answer some questions here,
but for my cell phone dies. Um, all right,
question number one. And as always,
I haven't read these fucking things,
so I'm going to have to read
the whole goddamn saying. Uh,
hey bill. Podcasts are great
to listen to every week.
Don't know if you're a smoker or not,
but was wondering how you felt about
those bullshit truth commercials just saw
one where it's these two bitches,
Jesus Christ.
It's two bitches dancing in the
streets singing. If you smoke,
it might take your life, but if you
don't, you might beat up your wife.
Once it sunk in what they were
saying about after about 10 seconds,
it just filled me with so much anger
and they would say that smokers are more
apt to beat their wives
without the nicotine.
I hope that secondhand
cancer does actually exist
in every one of those truths.
Motherfuckers get lung cancer
and dies a slow drawn out,
painful death. What do you think
about the truth commercials?
You know what I love about my listeners
is when they state their point, you'd,
you'd never have to wonder what
side of the issue they were on.
Like reverse politicians. Yeah.
I hate those commercials. Um,
those commercials actually make me want
to smoke and blow smoke in the people's
faces. You know, I don't wish that they
die a slow, painful death of cancer.
I don't take it to your level,
but just in your defense.
I haven't seen that
commercial yet, but, um,
I don't know why they've
never been able to make a,
the only good antismoking commercials
they haven't made was way back in the day.
And you kids can youtube this,
go onto youtube and check out.
Uh,
it was just great. Act or
one of my favorite actors of
all time now Yule Brenner,
and you should rent Westworld by the way,
will be a lot of people
don't know about he was in,
but basically he was dying of lung
cancer and right before he died he did a
commercial and went on TV and
he said, hi, I'm Yule Brenner,
I have lung cancer. By the time you
see this I will be dead. Don't smoke.
And it was just like, you know,
it was just delivered with Yule.
Brenner's typical like no bullshit,
a brand of speaking. So I think that
that's what they should do. When,
I want to say a few years ago,
didn't they have that?
I remember in New York they had
these ads maybe 10 years ago.
They just started showing people who
were dying of lung cancer. And uh,
actually that was too
brutal. Oh, that was right.
They had the guy who was holding
the odd the thing up to his throat.
My name is Dan, I had an
eight mile. Okay. You know,
he was doing that shit and then, you
know, it was just so over the top.
Everybody laughed. I Dunno. I Dunno dude.
You fucking rip those people so bad.
How exactly would you come about doing
a commercial where they're telling you
not to smoke? Um, I dunno,
I got to tell you this though.
I'm really,
I'm really annoyed with
smokers when there's,
they're still pissed how they
can't smoke in bars. And, uh,
I was down in Austin and people started
smoking in the bar and I can't, you know,
it's been so long since I've actually
smelled tent and it's fucking ridiculous.
It's really fucking,
I keep getting you walk out of it.
You felt like you've fought a fire.
Your eyes are all red. That burning,
it's in your clothes. It's disgusting.
I have no problem with people smoking.
I really don't smoke all you
want, but, uh, take it outside.
So I dunno.
I'm Kinda in the middle of it.
I think those truth commercials
do suck without a doubt. But, uh,
I'm glad that they put you people outside.
I think that's where you belong.
You know,
I think before you come back in,
they should hose you down
with some sort of perfume.
So we don't have to smell your shit. You
know what I mean? I'm trying to think of,
I have a habit or a hobby or a habit
or something that really annoys people
other than my general
continuous all. Uh, okay. Bill,
I got a couple of questions for you.
When was your big break? I mean,
when did you really start getting
paid seriously for your comedy?
How long did it take? Uh, okay,
well I've had some ups and
downs there. Fellow, let's see,
I um,
had a day job for the first three and a
half years and I paid off my car and I
was still living at home like a
fucking loser, but I was a smart loser,
so I was getting out of debt unlike,
I'm like this shit and I just saw
walking through the airport so bad.
These credit card companies are actually,
uh,
I think people's credit credit's so
bad that desperate for new customers,
you literally get off the plane and
they're like, excuse me sir, sir,
can I talk to you?
Do you guys want?
And they're basically giving
away a free plane ticket.
If you sign up for a mastercard,
a free plane ticket. Yeah,
set up for a mastercard if fucking 18 to
22% interest and you'll buy that ticket
about nine times during the
course of the year. You know what?
I think I might go over there and just
fuck up their sales pitch just by saying
it was seeing that ship, those, those,
those dumb fucks with football games,
you know, they hand it out like a free
tee shirt. If you sign up for a, uh,
you know, at Visa Card, I mean,
how much is the teacher? Honestly,
even if you go to a concert, it's
going to cost you like 35, 40 bucks,
which is ridiculous.
But uh,
you're going to pay that in
interest every month, you know,
go down the fucking clothes for less.
You go to footlocker,
you eat like three tee
shirts for 20 bucks. No,
I'd rather have this piece
of plastic dude. Uh, anyways,
uh, one was my big break.
I had a couple, um, let's see.
Uh,
I moved to New York and I
booked an acting Gig and uh,
I made a little chunk of money and
then the acting gig ended and then,
but I was able to live off that for a
year so I didn't have to get a day job
when I moved to New York.
But uh,
so I was living good in 97 and
then it was pretty rough. 98,
99, 2000, 2001.
But then I was like,
this is the all I was doing colleges,
I was doing like 9 million colleges
grossing about a hundred grand a year,
paying 20% commission that dropped it
down to 80 plus another 10 grand in
expenses,
dropped it down to 75 and then the
government would come in and take their
fucking half to drop it down to 35 and
then accountants and other bullshit drop
it. And I was making about 30 grand
a year. So it's basically, you know,
the cubicle Guy Shep. I was telling jokes
so my wife was still good. But yeah,
I was making about after all the bullshit,
I was make it about 30 grand a
year for a while. And then, uh,
I turned around and that was sort
of steady right up until, uh,
2005.
That was the year when I did,
uh, an HBO half hour. And
I got on Opie and Anthony,
and literally the month
I got on opiate Anthony,
my HBO special came out.
And then after that,
then people started coming to my shows.
Then they started making good money
and fortunately, and his continued.
Um,
so yeah,
I would say the first break came
when I made a little money on TV 96,
97,
and then the second time was 2005.
Did I even answer that? I get fucking
bored with that answer after a while. Um,
anything else I'm on to take?
Do,
do you ever still to stand up for 10
10 bucks for 15 minutes? Yes, I do.
Every single week at the firm
in New York. I do it, you know,
at the local clubs and when I'm in La,
I do it at the comedy store.
And the laugh factory in the front.
They don't pay.
They don't pay that
much, you know? So, um,
and one last question.
Oh yeah.
Do you think it's possible for a
comedian to do 10 spots a night,
getting paid $10 for every 15 minutes
at 10 different clubs? All right.
You sound like a guy who wants to do
comedy and you're trying to figure out how
you can make it financially.
You'll be fine just, just to,
you know, have a day job and
just keep hustling at night.
And this is a big thing.
Get yourself out of debt,
pay off your car.
If you get a brand new car,
fucking try and sell it and get something
quality that's used that you can
actually pay off and get
out of debt because, uh,
that's what we'll fuck you.
Oh yeah.
And don't knock up somebody that
you don't give a shit about.
That's another thing that will fuck you.
Um, other than that, you'll be fine. Okay.
Nobody makes shit when they
start off and then somehow,
I don't know what happens.
We start making money or write,
my cell phone's going to die.
So I think I've got to make this
actually short for once. I'm actually,
yeah, sorry guys. This is going
to be a real quick one. Um,
let me see if I got anything else.
No more questions that I can see.
Um, oh, here's somebody talking about my,
my sports obsession about going
to all the stadiums spill.
I totally respect your sports junkie
narrative session and if you've got the
means to do it, go for it. Why not?
I've seen a lot more money
spent on dumb shit before,
like a wife who doesn't work,
you know,
there's a lot of anger towards
women on these things. Jesus Christ.
Can I sound like my act. But even with
that, as I've listened to your podcast,
it sounds like you've been to pretty
much every sports venue in the United
States and Canada.
I asked to have you ask you a question,
what's the best fight you've ever
seen at a sporting event? Oh man,
that's a good one. Um, well let's
see his first, he says mine,
hands down it broad.
Then if you count wrestling is as a sport.
It was in 2000 WWF was at its height and
the entire crowd of 20,000 was drunk.
18 to 24 year olds showing
up in groups of 10.
And when one asshole from one group
would start shit with another asshole.
It wasn't a fight between two guys.
It was an all out 20 men bra watching
somebody get their nose broken over.
The fact that he's not a stone cold fan
is some funny shit to say the least.
All right. I've seen some
classic ones coming from Boston.
I remember going to an old Bruins,
the plan like the Nordiques of the North
Star. It's one of those great teams.
It doesn't play anymore in first of all,
I remember this guy had this
great sign and the upper deck,
it said a quote back has no deep.
And to me that was hilarious because I
was 18 years old and it was a dick joke.
Um, but anyways, uh,
I dunno what happened.
Like these Bruins fans got into
it with the Nordi Canadian fans.
I can't remember what. So they
would just check like an idiot.
I run over,
I learned my lesson,
I ran over to look at the
fight you ever go to do that.
Never run over to look at a bra
because it's like a tornado.
You don't know where it's going to go
and all of a sudden you're in the fucking
middle of it and there's
no bathtub to jump into it.
So that's basically what happened to
fucking fight spilled over onto me.
And I was literally impaled on one
of those pillows. Old yellow rails,
I don't know. People from Boston member,
right. And all I remember was some guy,
I don't know what he did when he tried
to push this cop down the stairs and I
dunno how to this day,
this cop did it,
but he literally was walking down the
stairs with this guy and he had a handful
of his neck.
It's like he was carrying him like
luggage and an inside of his fist was the
guy's juggler.
And this guy was literally turning blue
and it's the cop walked down the stairs.
He just kept repeatedly stating,
tried to push me down the stairs. Huh?
Type push me down the stairs.
Huh? In this guy's eyes.
I thought he was going to kill him,
but I don't know.
I don't think I've ever seen,
I've just seen just haymakers throne.
I'd never seen like a 20 on 20 Brah.
I went to a ranger's island just game in
1989 when a buddy of mine was going to
Hofstra as back when everybody
was coked up. And I saw some, uh,
guys who were way too old to be
fighting going at it in the upper deck.
And I got to MIT.
I was terrified because I felt like a
man without a country and I was going to
be discovered, you know, I
felt like I felt like that,
that old guy in the beginning of scar
face, they get stabbed in that tent city.
You know, I'm sitting there
trying to act like I'm, you know,
I'm one of the group and I really don't
give a fuck about their cause. But, um, I,
you know what, I'd probably have to
think about that a little bit longer.
My cell phone's going to die.
I'm kind of mentally in a panic right
now cause I just babbled for about Oh,
20 minutes, and I'm worried
that it's not going to save it.
So I'm going to cut it short
here. Uh, thanks to everybody
who came out to Austin.
Um, so next week send me some stuff that
you find in sports he find annoying.
Please keep sending in the under room.
Uh, next week I will be in town in La,
so I'll give a longer podcast.
And uh, in November I got the,
uh, DC Improv and in plain
xannies in Nashville.
And, uh, hopefully in the next
month or so I will be getting a,
I'll be getting some dates for
2009. All right. That is it.
Everybody have a good week and I will
you next week.
Next Monday night.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].